you were very busy right now and then I
remember you have a child how old now
he's nine he's nine how do you juggle
the work with having the nine-year-old
it's got to be difficult it's hard but
Henry is very parental with me he's um
you know it was just him and me until I
fell in love with my best mate um four
years ago it was really just Henry and I
and he um like he sat me down he's like
he has a really deep voice he does he
sounds like he
you know got a show in the Poconos he's
like mommy you got you got to sit down
come sit down I like what I don't this
is your nine-year-old yeah let me sit
down I got to talk to you about
something it's alucino he's terrified
he's terrified he's not he's fantastic
so he's like sit down Mommy I was like
what's up and he's like I got to tell
you a couple things and I was like what
is it and he's like okay so I'm sorry
but the Easter Bunny the Tooth Fairy and
Santa Claus not real he he broke it to
you he broke it to me and I'm I'm crying
at the loss of innocence and the sadness
and the fact that he this was when he
was like six or seven years old right
and he's like don't cry mommy it's okay
you're GNA get over he's so good he's
such a good dude I love him he's such a
good dude you just broke some bad news
to Andy uh I'm sorry
Andy a Andy you can't just say stuff
like that but Andy it's okay you don't
have any teeth left anyway I don't I
don't that's going to say the Tooth
Fairy was the the one that hurt cuz
that's
how are you would you say that you are a
strict parent I'm not strict but I am
English and there's this there's this
maners thing that I had just not
literally beaten into me because I
wasn't beaten as a child my mother's in
the dressing room watching nobody to hit
me right but um what's the stress again
you were not beaten no no but we but
manners were a big deal and I would be I
would be taken in a restaurant if I had
Bad Manners I'd be taken and slung in
the car and they would barely crack the
window right so kids come over to our
house to eat dinner and they're all
spaghetti bolog andise and I'm like
knock it off click oh no that was meant
to be funny no it's not ter I'm I'm like
their worst nightmare of sort of AI Mary
Poppins like awful style like if you
want jelly and ice cream you'd better
eat your spaghetti bise
nicely stop we do c Queen yeah it's very
I can see
that
frightening how can you have any pudding
if you don't eat some meat exactly no
told meat you won't get any pudding and
they're all but they they do laugh at me
you know my mother very strict about
manners and she used to say that no one
was going to respect me or like me if I
didn't sit up straight her big thing was
elbows off the table elbows off the
table your mouth and then I'd go to
school and all the cool kids were just
shoving food in their any hole in their
face you know and they were likee they
didn't never understood that but it's
good I think it's good to teach miners
you think that's a British Thing versus
an American thing so you know how
there's like The Stereotype like there's
a stereotype that the British are that's
super upy and there's a stereotype in
England that Americans are sort of
slightly unou which I think is unfair
but let me explain smart answer in this
room
yeah also I'm one of you now as well I'm
I became an American citizen so anyway
the the thing is I have a feeling that
when you got rid of the Red Coats I feel
like it was like we're going to get rid
of the Red Coats we're going to get rid
of the tea we're going to get rid of the
church and state and we're going to get
rid of the manners so we want to put our
elbows on the table we want to eat a
hamburger and it was all I think it was
all in a reaction to the British it's
really just like
right see I
do you know I mean a bit like that yeah
it just looked like you gave me the
double finger that's all I know well
that's if yeah if the sounds down it's
going to look bad if the sounds down if
someone's watching it while they're
doing something else they see the
beautiful mini driver go like this to
Conan and then you know they'll be
asking what did Conan do yeah then they
just saw me do it back to you and things
are getting really
unpleasant